hey leute ich jetzt wieder eure test
wanne und heute werden der koreanische
beauty produkte testen bzw asiatische
ich glaube die gadgets die ich geholt
habe sind nicht alle aus korea deswegen
nenne ich vielleicht auch asiatische
beauty expo die produkte testen ich
hätte nie gedacht dass ich das sage aber
mir liegt mittlerweile hautpflege sehr
am herzen weil ich gemerkt habe was für
ein besseres hautbild man erreichen kann
wenn man seine haut auch wirklich
schlägt und dann kam vor sechs monaten
einen kooperationspartner in spieler und
ich freue mich tatsächlich sehr dass ich
euch das jetzt vorstellen kann weil ich
es schon lange getestet habe und zwar
geht oder ebola ist eine koreanische
hautpflegeserie die den cache youtube
nach deutschland holt und zwar mit
vielen steps und die piraten vor sechs
monaten an die produkte zugeschickt und
zuerst hatte ich so den reinigungsschaum
und die cremes und dicken baum megabit
werner und dann habe ich noch ein paar
monaten gesagt ihr könnt ich vielleicht
auch die anderen sachen ausprobieren und
dann haben sie es mir freundlicherweise
zugeschickt und zu den anderen steps
gehört noch vermisst heft das ist ein
toner ein serum und eine maske des
stocks ich bin begeistert was soll ich
sagen mein haupt hat sich wirklich
verbesserung geruch her ist die abend
creme mein favorit weil sie sehr nach
lavendel liegt aber jetzt nicht
übertrieben sondern so dass man wenn man
ins bett geht und dann so seine abend
gewichts routine gemacht hat diesen
leichten lavendelduft in der nase hat
und an sich denkt jetzt ist so schlafen
angesagt das ist so eine richtig schöne
abend routine mittlerweile geworden und
das ist so quasi der letzte step und
dann werde ich müde und wenn es ums
make-up entfernen geht bin ich wirklich
großer fan geworden von diesem länder
nimmt ihn einfach mit dem spachtel reibt
sich den auf die trockene haut
tatsächlich und dann nimmt man ein
warmes tuch was ist quasi auch mit
diesem set gab und schmiert es so ab und
dann geht man mit der bubble dabei rein
und reinigt die haut mit dem schaum und
seit ich dann die anderen drei schritte
habe also den toner und das serum und
die maske merklich möglich ist meine
haut so ein glänzen hat aber nicht so
ein öliges glänzen sondern so ein
gesundes feuchtes
sie sieht einfach sie sieht einfach gut
aus ich bin einfach richtig happy
und das war es jetzt mit meiner qvc
sendung ich kann euch die produkte sehr
empfehlen ich als mischhaut bin super
zufrieden und werden diese produkte auf
jeden fall weiterhin benutzen gerade
auch weil es ganz schön übersichtlich
ist und wenn ihr euch das ganze mal
genauer anschauen wollt dann habe ich
natürlich in einem für box ein link den
ihr folgen könnt und auch einen
rabattcode mit dem rabattcode vanessa 30
gibt es 30 auf das sortiment viel spaß
beim shoppen und jetzt geht es weiter
mit den anderen gadgets es ist ein
trugen drücker und ganz ehrlich das ist
ein problem das ich hab' ich weiß noch
nicht ob dieses ding mein problem lösen
wird aber es ist super gut wir haben ja
eine lehre zum 108
mein gott ich meine das prinzip muss man
nicht erklären das ist wirklich ich weiß
es nicht ob das wirklich die zahnpasta
so gut hoch drückt und das alle
zahnpasten drücker leute gut zum
dickwerden rede gegeben
danny enttäuscht
was habe ich noch an meiner wunderkiste
zuallererst ich habe auf der seite sind
an zug geholt der irgendwie 90 euro oder
so gekostet hatte ich meine für hose und
oberteil ist ein guter deal aber die
qualität ist jetzt nicht das was ihr
erhofft habe das sähe ganz und gar nicht
geschadet das war ein experiment wert
vielleicht für halloween kommt einfach
zum nächsten produkt id herr papers ich
kenne papers fürs gesicht wenn man ein
ollie face hat herr paper von wir noch
nie gesehen im bunker drauf hier habe
ich bestimmt ein bisschen her als ich
meine es ist eine witzige idee gerade
wenn man irgendwie unterwegs ist merkt
man als ölig geworden was wird die
gesellschaft zu mir sagen ich bin jetzt
gerade über miley face damit gegangen
und da sieht man dann so eine reaktion
auf dem papier also ich nicht genug
woher aber jetzt gut braucht man es gibt
trocken
aber es ist ein schönes ding to go wo
wir gerade bei ponys sind und zwar habe
ich das schon oft im koreanischen serien
gesehen und ihr wisst koreanische serien
sind wirklich ein ebenbild von korea ich
den mädels sich in den serien fertig
gemacht haben laufen die immer so form
date oder somit zum ding noch in den
haaren unternehmen sie zeit raus und
gehen raus und dann haben wir so ein
schönes lockeres pony bevor wir zur
schminkt abteilung kaum habe ich etwas
gefunden ich glaube es ist so anti
doppelkinn also hier auf den bildern
sieht man es geht darum heißt diese form
schön straff zu ziehen
also ganz ehrlich sieht aus als ob ich
mir aus dem orthopädie haus geholt hat
oha hier sind sogar so druckpunkte die
stinken bisschen aber es okay wenn die
druckpunkte machen wir ein bisschen 10
ha das wird voll straff sein
ich glaube koreaner haben auch
grundsätzlich kleinere gesicht als ich
so der durchschnitts koreaner sag ich
mal okay und lange trägt man das ist
einfach koreanisch natürlich das kann
jetzt gelesen
ich glaube aber ich hab es zu eng mal
ganz kurz hier ja ins sitz fühlt sich
mein gewicht nicht zu zerquetschen
tragekomfort ist okay
ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher über
die einstellungen wie eng man das tragen
sollte wir machen aber einfach mal
weiter mit dem nächsten ich wollte schon
immer eine dusche oder gar nicht
ausprobieren aber ich hege herum
eingriff ja ich glaube es macht sinn
und wenn wir schon mal beim thema
duschen sind sorry da musst dich zu
sagen zu klein für meinen kopf möchte
zum großen kopf ab
ich hab immer zum rechten großen kopf so
ein handtuch für den kopf deshalb biene
schauer cap nur dass sie deine haare
verfügung
jetzt widmen wir uns der beauty und ich
habe etwas gefunden was so seltsam
aussieht aber so viel sinn macht eine
schere mit einer sitzung kam für die
1000 braun
das macht so viel sinn in letzter zeit
gibt es oft meine augenbrauen irgendwie
den kragen
so sieht ein bisschen nach weisheitszahn
op es aus oder wie funktioniert das so
und dann kämme ich habe das macht
richtig sein kann sogar ein cam und dann
kommen sie die haare dadurch und da wo
ich sie dann abgeschnitten haben möchte
ich glaube das ist das beste gadget
aller zeiten okay so und dann runter wo
die schere schneidet nicht ganz so gut
aber ich glaube man wirklich von kein
unterschied doch ihr vorhaben nicht
getan ist die echt kurz geschnitten aber
schon zu kurz mit musik sagt dann seite
genauso kurz sein und sind sie uneben
aber mir gefällt es irgendwie die sind
jetzt so die sehne zu ordentlich
irgendwie aus ich glaube man hätte aber
auch viel vorsichtiger sein müssen
nachdem ich meine augenbrauen versaut
habe kommt jetzt große reveal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wird sich auf jeden fall angespannter an
ich glaube ich habe mir sogar ein loch
in die augenbrauen geschnitten
ich habe das gefühl hier heißt es
wirklich strafbar und ich habe hier mehr
also hier ist jetzt so ein bisschen
dicker und dafür ist es hier flacher ich
habe auf jeden fall schon ist man sein
gesicht damit ein bisschen formen kann
ob das jetzt so wichtig ist es eine
andere frage aber man könnte und dafür
einsetzt die augenbrauen versaut haben
hätten wir sie mit einer augenbrauen
schablone das finde ich wirklich geil
und ist es auch korea ist korea korea
korea korea korea augenbrauen malen ist
schwierig viele leute kommen nicht damit
zurecht und was ist da praktischer als
augenbrauen schablonen man hält sich die
schablone ins auge und malt einfach nur
der form nach zu einfach um wahr zu sein
so jetzt müssen wir uns nur für eine
form entscheiden also ich würde sagen
diese form ist die typische die nummer 1
also dann hält man sich
ich glaube das macht voll sind vor allem
wenn man sich die augenbrauen tönen
möchte willkommen bei vanessa class
sozusagen schritt nummer eins kämen ich
fang mal an mit meinem normalen hier
augenbrauen tool ich will diese
augenbraue nehmen die am wenigsten nach
meiner eigenen aussieht oder die mit
einer leichten kurve ich lege jetzt
diese schablone eigentlich
selbsterklärend festhalten und jetzt
nach 9
mein gott ich merke jetzt schon dass es
vielleicht nicht die beste idee war
naja wenn man jetzt noch quasi
ausbessert ich glaub ich bin fan
probieren sie mal die andere seite aus
ich glaube das ist eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht ich meine freunde habe ich
jetzt eine perfekte zweite augen braucht
das kriegt man ja nie hin dass sie
gleich aussehen ja dann einfach der
schablone nach willkommen bei bereit
es ist nicht schlecht
und um das ganze zu fixieren benutzen
wir noch augenbrauen bruder war und
schon zehn unserer augenbrauen ready für
den tag kommen das ist in ordnung weil
jetzt sehr markante augenbrauen kein
make-up drauf deswegen sie das gerade
komisch aus wenn darum brauchen sie
ziemlich gleich aus es liegt an einer
schablone
ich habe noch was für gewichte man kann
sich halt dieses orthopädie band ins
gesicht machen oder man benutzt hat so
ein massagegerät bester film der welt
leute ungelogen fühlten
ich weiß nicht ob ich mich schöner macht
aber entspannt auf jeden fall mein
angesprochen kiefer kategorie
augenbrauen schöner machen haben wir
jetzt durch wir haben unser gesicht
massiert jetzt geht's ans meter ein
gadget was ich eher so für mich selber
geholt hat weil das wirklich ein problem
von mir ist so einen beauty schwamm
halter muss ich das jetzt nicht
demonstrieren ihr wisst selber was es
heißt finde ich sehr gut das ist eine
schnelle lösung und das sieht süß aus es
ist eine kleine katze so und jetzt kommt
das was wir an koreanischen make up wir
haben es sich richtig einfach gemacht
und zwar benutzen sie solche dosen das
ganz schlau weil dann haben sich hier
dieses schwämmchen und da unten dann
drücken sie ihren applikator drücken sie
dann in diesen make-up schwamm und dann
kriegen sie so eine gute menge an
make-up und können das dann so auftragen
und das beste an diesem ding ist man
kann sein eigenes make-up reinmachen ich
weiß nicht wie viel man da rein machen
sollte aber ich mache mal so 12345
darauf kommt jetzt unser schwamm so
jetzt kommt s make up dadurch und man
damit so ein bisschen was davon ab
sondern habe ich was auf meinem links ja
doch sondern hat man halt so eine menge
drauf ist nicht viel ist aber es reicht
um halt wirklich nur so die haut bis hin
zu korrigieren also ich mach das prinzip
und jetzt das letzte produkt ich fand es
ziemlich bescheuert weil ich nicht
glaube dass leute damit würdig probleme
haben dann habe ich aber daran
8 das bei koreanern das glaube ich so
ist dass die wimpern ein bisschen kürzer
sind also sie haben nicht von natur aus
so lange volle wimpern glaube ich jetzt
und deswegen macht es vielleicht bei
asiaten sind dieses ding so ein schutz
dass man wimperntusche auftragen kann
ohne seine haut zu treffen und wenn ich
jetzt an meine teenager-zeit denke doch
dann hätte ich das auch gebraucht gerade
für unten bornum sogar aufpassen ist
ganz schön spitze ich meine es ist schon
gut so anlegen
es macht super sinn ich hab noch nie so
lange unter drin gehabt kann mich gerade
noch nicht entscheiden ob es
stressfreier ist oder mehr stress macht
diese methode aber ergebnisse sowie das
produkt kommt aus japan nicht korea okay
leute wenn ihr augen konnte nicht mögt
dann scheidet weg war das macht ja wenig
sinn guck mal wie man das dann so hoch
sorry ich bin gerade hin und weg vor vor
allem konnte ich immer diese hinteren
wimpern konnte ich mich bei mannheim
gescheitert
also leute wenn ihr kurze wimpern habe
und schwierigkeiten beim anmalen könnt
euch dieses teil
ich meine das ergebnis ist jetzt nicht
viel krasser aber ich hab's gefühl schon
gut weiß auch nicht genau wofür hier das
ende ist das wird nicht beschrieben zum
camp sinnvoll da könne man durchkämmen
ich bin begeistert ich finde ich habe
eine totale wandlung durchgemacht also
sorry ich bin nicht die gleiche wie noch
vor für mich ungefähr eine stunde für
euch wahrscheinlich zehn minuten
welche produkt habe ich besonders
gefeiert natürlich je bruder und dieses
ding eigentlich fand ich die meisten
sachen total sinnvoll ich freue mich
jetzt auch dass ich sie habt also
augenbrauen schablone macht sinn gerade
wenn man sich nicht so gut auskennt die
schere war jetzt nicht so optimal ich
habe mir die augenbrauen dollar
abgeschlossen
aber er braucht das gefühl dass es mir
ganz gute steht also vielleicht ist es
auch gar nicht so schlecht dass für die
wimpern war jetzt fantastisch hier für
das pony super auch wenn ich es nicht
ausprobieren konnte die app kann auch
nichts mit falsch machen
ich glaube wenn man ab und zu mal dieses
ding trägt kann man echt ein bisschen
seine gesichtsform optimieren rundum bin
ich zufrieden ich liebe es einfach für
solche videos produkte zu kaufen
für die man vielleicht sonst nicht so
wirklich geld ausgeben wollen würde und
jetzt habe ich sie und freu mich total
darüber
ich freue mich wenn euch das video
gefallen hat und ich ein bisschen
entertain konnte danke ihr bruder für
die kooperation ich finde den link in
der video beschreibung und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder und
bleibt gesund bleibt happy und schreibt
was nettes wenn ich was mir einfällt bis
dann tschüss